hi Joe welcome to the show thank you for
joining us in studio we have Dave Roop
do you yeah no they said that they're
just [ __ ] on me cuz they're saying I
finally gave it professional I'm not
[ __ ] you you did a great job thank
you wait what you come back from break
I've never heard him do it well that's
like having sex with a girl even dating
for eight years he goes oh my god I
finally came for eight years but it was
really and you always come he just came
back from break really really really
well yeah yeah well you should have seen
him I saw him go to the bathroom and it
was just a beeline down the hallway yeah
he had no he didn't no eye contact with
anybody I was even like I didn't see him
there was a group like a rap group down
there and I was like no no vision we
have Taylor Swift coming into the
building today
who's we the building we the company
seriously attempt since they like pump
us all into one giant these are like all
that prevent assassination drapes
they're not the drapes we have and I'm
such a [ __ ] dope I asked the guy
there's a giant guy putting them the
drama who's coming into the egos I'm
just the drape guy wait a minute those
drapes weren't for me no llores divorce
yeah okay yeah we talk we talk about
Louie today of course and we talk about
this weird and this the ambiguity the
sexual stuff what is consent and what's
not concern do you find you run it this
stuff on the roll where you're like I
think she wants to do this but I'm not
and I didn't mean [ __ ] e I mean anything
no I mean I think that's anyone that's
that's been on a date you've been it's
like it's a good date and then at the
end you're like I think I think I pulled
my dick out now oh no no she just wants
more butter have you ever missed red
I've missed ready and not to the extent
of jerked off and I think I'm Israeli
you've never stripped naked and jerked
off should be naked I'm too much body
shame I can't all I can say is that's
never been a thing for me where I'm just
like hey do you mind if I just
cough I'm trying to be real quick like
that I don't know what that is but I had
a friend go to jail for that and that is
the craziest thing I thought I thought
he was just one in a billion I was just
like whoa that's my friend like what the
[ __ ] yeah yeah he went to jail for it
and it was just so weird he was he was
doing it in movie theaters in like like
on him he'll go to a matinee and just
jerk off yeah like poorni Caesar he's
gonna like no no it was like legit
movies and he yeah because you know
movies how many girls go to that first
dates like one and then yeah he was
doing that and then taking off and then
finally got caught and it tripped me out
cuz it was just like this is a guy you
say hey you know no you just beat real
creepy about it Wow the thing is is that
we is so weird even think of like yeah
but we all do weird [ __ ] I mean everyone
is into weird [ __ ] the issue is you
can't do it to somebody without asking
like you could do it at whatever you're
into fantastic but you can't just walk
into a room and do it you're right there
I've always said that it's like that you
know it doesn't matter who you are what
you are it's like why don't you close
that door you're that other dude carries
it with him
why you had a line on your website years
ago something about the amount of
gallons of fluids you've lost that's up
from some website or something and
whatever you I'm sure you remember was
it a list of lists was it I had put in a
fictional a fictional list of lists I
just didn't a rubber quit your thinking
about the list or the amount of gallons
because definitely gallons like these
from these made-up lit and one of them
was something about fluids dripped on me
by a prostate and none of them existing
yeah yeah yeah what you talking about
like you said I had lost like 87 gallons
of fluid on this website
like so many I thought you can't even
remember the gallon
the fluid this statement is such a
normal see for Jim he can't remember at
all right 87-84 like if I was like a Joe
who's that guy you said hi to yesterday
you're like a bunch of this is why I
love joko r joko is the Town Hall
tonight he sold out the bugatti atlantic
city sold out silver legacy casino reno
sold out if you want to see Joe November
18th reading Civic Auditorium in Redding
California and April 27th way in advance
in Boston because you still come in when
you're sold out that's why I love Joker
oh yeah we get annoyed comics like we
figure it out quick they're like oh he
actually had something come up and then
we just checked the website and he sold
out and we're like oh he's just around
for you and you just cuz you [ __ ]
stole tickets you want to come in so
thank you for coming in anyway are you
kidding me I'm with Jim and Sam right
now in the right wing very niche thing
you other gay people think like wow man
you're selling out by being as right as
you are but I'm not right well you know
the Advocate which nobody reads this
crap nobody cares about any of that but
they wrote a piece on how Peter Thiel
you know Peter Walker yeah which is
amazing right and that's why I met Hogan
by the way through him oh yeah but they
wrote a piece how he's not gay because
he's a Republican and it's like I'm
pretty sure one thing makes you gay and
absolutely that thing particularly well
you will be embraced by the gay
community do you know how awful is when
you think you're doing a great job in
your bow I brush my tongue
[Laughter]
I'll just leave it white leave the film
on there how much I would wanna hear a
Jim Norton gag and then somebody else
goes seriously experience some things
and other things you're just such a
little ruckus awful bleeding you brush
your tongue while we're on this topic
how did you end up meeting Hulk Hogan oh
[Laughter]
it doesn't even matter he was at a
speaking at eels company because
obviously teal backed the lawsuit which
is amazing he does and anyway so I end
up in an office with with Peter with
Hogan and one other guy for about two
hours so I got spent two hours with
Hogan and he is I mean you're around a
lot of wrestlers to say he's huge isn't
even the right thing everything about
this man his eyeballs were the size of
her head are massive he put his hand
around my neck and it literate like he
was like he was like holding a straw
like every but he was so cool how did
that happened how did what happened on
your net our reason yeah he was just he
was just awesome and the guys trying to
figure it out he wants to be like a
player in the world now again and he's
trying to figure it out I did he's
awesome when he and well I've met him a
few times and one time when we took a
photo he was like he's like put her in
on my neck brother really like okay and
I'm foot and he he set me up for a
collar-and-elbow tie-up you know like in
wrestling and like his hand hit my neck
and it was like the biggest media spawn
you ever felt yeah and everything about
him I need he basically is Robocop at
this point everything has been replaced
27 times hips knees eyes legs no oh
brother
how you doing brother said he said
actually is kind of funny he's like you
know sometimes the the Hulk Hogan guy
takes over he's like you know in my real
name's Terry and I'm a normal guy he's
like sometimes but I'm just walking down
the street people like hey brother like
it's
like holding the Hulk inside I mean
everybody in wrestling still says
brother like off-cam oh he started that
what do you what are you gonna do
brother
yeah what do you do brother when this
hand slaps you brother I'm gonna come
[Laughter]
like if you said to somebody like oh no
I just brother in with Hulk Hogan for
like two hours
is he still banned from WWE yeah wait
why is he big cuz he dropped
n-bombs talking about Brooke I guess
there's audio of him I guess he was
saying it in that sex tape where he was
mad that Brooke was dating a black guy
or there was a private moment that got
exposed and she was in a very weakened
state he was a weakened state I think it
was it was terrible to use a private
recording against you but also I think
there were other stuff would come out
and no other stuff has so I think the
reason that the WWE reacted that way is
because Hogan knew it was on the tape
and didn't tell them okay maybe yeah you
know what I mean and so and so really
the anger was in this thing of like if
you had told us we would have been
prepared and we could have like you
could like the fact that this just comes
out and it's news to us like that's why
but we got it we got to get you out of
here I believe he'll be back yeah he's a
brother like you know the brother is
gonna be background yeah well he was the
face of WWE if it wasn't for him that
company be nowhere that's right come on
and everywhere he went it was like
next-level oh I was such a wrestling
fanatic man it was just like my favorite
just all those old guys man Shawn
Michaels the rock Austin like I love
them man yeah I still young guys I'm
older than you so it sound like the
young guys I mean jake the snake' for me
was like I thought he was like the
coolest human ever like documentary
actually haven't seen it I know I know
everyone keeps telling me to watch it
yeah
I interviewed rowdy rowdy yeah yeah he
that was an amazing interview because he
was talking about what he had to do to
become a professional wrestler how do
you go to Mexico and lie about his age
and I was like wow I didn't even know
there was an underground world for this
I thought you just oh yeah audition and
get the gig
comics had a bad berry year let's go to
Mexico yeah get real there this back in
the time where they thought it was real
fighting was when Piper was starting
like they wouldn't smarten anybody up
until what's that mean like let them
know let them know what the deal was
yeah yeah yes is scripted they were the
you know they wouldn't tell anybody when
they first got in the business you had
to be in the business for a little while
before you got smartened up to it so
like your first few matches you'd be
getting the ring they would just kicked
the [ __ ] out of you for real but then
you wouldn't you hit back don't they
know that you're they're professionals
so you're not gonna be able to because
they can legit fight and they would
because they didn't want the business
getting exposed yeah like they didn't
want some kid having one match he gets
smartened up then he leaves and tells
all his friends so like they wouldn't
smarten you up until you were locked in
so in the meantime you're just getting
the [ __ ] kicked like in Vietnam they
said the new guy I like he's what his
life is worth less the new guy's life is
worth less because he hasn't suffered as
much right if you go the teenage boys
early mmm exactly that's the worst way
to walk into something right yeah you
guy hey you're worth less that whole out
oh it's a piece of [ __ ] are you are you
comfortable
I'm not you said me in the nuga I'm not
uncomfortable like I know it's even on
people I know a long time just I'm not a
comfortable point you a comfortable
person yeah III I just like to be I'm
that guy that just likes to hug like
like every time I see you I go for that
big yeah I love but then the face Jim
gives you like what about a hand when
you put your arm put his arm out I
didn't know if it was a handshake and
then a hug I'm fine with a husband I'm a
hug guy I'm that guy do not like the
germs of handshakes that to man that's
just it creeps me out like at the end of
the show you shake a thousand hands then
you just feel the film underhand
everything yeah man I had Rick he's also
offensive at the at the merch line
you're just I had Richard Lewis on my
show
and you know on curb he's always doing
the fist bump with Larry yeah so I gave
him the fist bump because I figured he
doesn't want to touch anybody and then
at the end when he was saying goodbye to
me as he's walking out of my house he
put his hand on my on my cheek he's like
oh that's nice that was fun well you
just house yet in my garage the whole
thing I'm Aaron kind of started the
whole garage
yeah yeah but I really the door so it
can't open or no one door is sealed the
other one less sealed that's a really
important question ask you guys it's for
a youtube show I'm not know if you're a
hugger
yeah you must deal with a lot of people
that like don't know what to do like
they go in for the yeah yeah I normally
will say like if they don't have to do
all usually say press belts with daddy
[Laughter]
no I think you again this is a
conversation about mixing messages here
yeah exactly
just saying hello is not consent for me
that's just how i hug go is your [ __ ]
belt buckles touch jens to Jen's that's
a deep hug Jim like I don't go that far
it's like yeah it's under the chest but
like to get the belt buckles closer
right I want sure you're trying to walk
right through the person for a good hug
your nipples and shins snake your legs a
snake full body contact yeah yeah yeah
I've just decided that I'm gonna leave
with just a high-five yeah yeah you know
where the the hug really came from also
is like you know when you shake that
hand there's always that one guy that
you know your hands are clammy like
don't even offer the hand but they
always yeah but don't you ever like like
they just dipped it in a bucket of water
water and just went for the handshakes
like come on you know that's you know
that slimy what do you do that yeah but
don't you ever like I don't know I'm not
so bad with handshakes but like don't
you ever like smell a person and it's
not like they stink yeah but they just
have this natural yeah thing of like you
can just smell it yeah yeah yeah like I
don't want to be that close to that
person
yeah well it's after when you do gigs
and people are coming up to you after an
you have to shake like hands and I I'm
not a germaphobe in any way whatsoever
but I do
feel like at the end I'm like I gotta
put my hand in some sort of nuclear
device to light yeah it's one of those
things where you just wash it after you
know I just wash my [ __ ] hands yeah I
do too by the way I think the hugging is
a sports thing I think that we saw
players hitting each other on the ass
and hugging and I think that was men's
desire to be alright plus we've gotten
more affectionate more more you look
back after World War two nobody hugged
or touched each other yeah yeah just men
but there's a sports figures doing it
yeah and a little more comfortable all
right if two linebackers can [ __ ] hug
okay next thing you know you're married
to a dude used by the door question what
were you going for and why would I have
a door that can't open well you're
always thinking more in the fact that
it's winter here forgetting you're in LA
and I was thinking how cold it must be
in there so did you seal the garage or
so it does yeah well the do we built a
wall the the garage door is now fake
there's an actual wall enter through the
home not like you know that the idea
that Jim may ask a question that goes
nowhere is very real Sam it's the sign
of a partner Silence of the Lambs like I
didn't know what you were picturing in
the in the basement you following me
around the green thing I have a bunch of
business cards I was gonna drop I love
his little dance did you guys you guys
see what Shawn Parker was saying about
Facebook yesterday yes I did that it was
like God did not that there's this yeah
do you have the preyed on the weakness
right I think Travis has audio you have
the audio Sean Parker you're trying you
just said you had it ready yeah you just
a minute I was homebound asleep tech dog
who's they go hug talk huh yeah Sean
Parker who's everybody knows from the
Facebook movie is one of the people who
helped founded yep Wow I guess he didn't
really he's not really one of the
founders of Facebook cuz if you watch
the movie it's
like he kind of just muscled edwardo out
of it Napster he did a yeah yeah and
then he jumped on Facebook in the very
beginning but he's been out of Facebook
for a long time but he was talking about
and now he says Spotify are you alright
is he an alien how do you jump onto
three like legendary I think Shawn
Parker John starts Potter I literally
just have two hundred thousand into
Friendster he just bought a dotnet yeah
he's not he's also not with Spotify he's
also he's really good at being a party
lesson spy to and it be not a part of
these companies what what he did he was
one of them but they pay me give them
out my money yeah yeah it's like it's
like us leaving is equivalent to him
leaving it's like a lot to leave yeah
yeah like if we let us four hundred
thousand dollars exactly
but do you have the audio of it how come
you know the audio because [ __ ] low have
told me that it was in there and it's
not where is he he's going to get it
what he said was in there we so it has
to go get audio what is imported into
the system so that I can we plays
YouTube do we have from you to let's
just play
I mean it would be quicker if Shore just
got it off me too so what happened he
gives me this thing of like here's the
audio that we have yeah and I'm like
okay let me let me give a little like
I'll get the backstory so Travis has
time to pull it up yeah and then I'm
like hit the audio Travis and he goes no
you're a [ __ ] supposed to put in is
he supposed to problem and it's 100% his
is his issue
so should we ask him why it's not in the
system I apologize it won't happen again
I'm sorry Jim there's only one way to
talk to him where did you learn your
trade guys who I have never I have never
in my life heard somebody say I
apologize someone happen again more
times than this he told me that no whew
wait that was you that was really heavy
for something else oh my god my time in
it I apologize I apologize that's right
after he like spews all over the place I
apologize it's all gonna be replaced by
an iPad whoa I've officially like
everything that Anthony adds to the show
I've got on my iPad I apologize it won't
happen again we're not here for the next
two months yeah yeah nobody would ever
know the difference
yeah no that's that all he says that
where is he he was slowly walking up the
hall I think he's going in the is he
going in the booth he's slowly walking
slowly yes why is he being like it
basically why Travis could we get it
just comma just killing us coming in oh
good oh that's smart of him it's cool
just sit down in the electric chair yeah
I'm sorry it won't happen I'm sorry I
look I apologize someone happy yeah
you're marking nice and slow yeah take
your time yeah why not
anything on what happened we wish we
went to a clip it wasn't there and you
put on the list I doubt I did I put in
to let you know I like I like the iPod
version I apologize someone having a
successful folder and delet and it
loaded this morning and I thought it was
in there and it wasn't did it it did you
did you did load it I loaded in it nice
I did you check hundred percent loaded
in it did you check that it was there I
didn't check in to let because you're
right you didn't check where I don't
know I didn't check the system in delet
but all's I know is I put it in the
successful folder I dragged it over into
the let and it was transferred into the
ironic that they would call it a
successful folder it is yes since it was
no the other ones still are loaded or no
just that there's nothing from today
what Satterlee the other ones might not
be nothing from today miraculously I had
no trouble doing it you didn't knots
here it's ready
Anthony what's going on come on man
Travis - Travis is saying that he you
can't hear what Travis is saying put
your headphones on buddy just we can
hear you or if you get
there's something else bothering him Jim
I can tell Travis body language look at
him yes
Travis going on just said that he just
loaded that there was no problem and
yesterday's stuff it's not in there
either I was having a problem with the
let the first day and I just sent them
to Travis and heal up I've loaded it but
then I I did it two days ago and it went
through and it said it was under the
ones that trav I saw Travis load so I
assumed that they were in there Travis
that correct I mean he did it correctly
once but you're not supposed to put
anything in the successful folder that
it's not where it goes this is a little
like you know boring rot no no but I
mean like like getting technical like he
didn't put it where it's supposed to be
that boring like my friends used to love
it when my dad disciplined me he didn't
put in the right folder correct okay
Anthony comment he tried to sing it in
play right folder Travis a no it's a
problem once you put in successful that
I thought it comes up automatically no
you don't remember remember one time I
remember I was like see this is what
happens when when you assume things and
you went like this
I apologize someone happened and then
you just went right back to it just
assuming things a guy that's probably
there I put it in the folder so I'm sure
it's gonna pop up can you get him saying
I thought I'd put it was successful for
recorded just get that I thought I put
it in a successful for I need a computer
Anthony in here yeah yeah I want a
successful folders so Travis he what did
he know that he shouldn't have done that
or is that something no one ever showed
him well I mean he's done it correctly
before he's done it correctly before
yeah I did it the same way I usually do
it that's it's the weirdest thing in the
world if he doesn't stop saying things
it's so strange I always do it wrong
every time he [ __ ] up he just says it's
so weird did not we it's not what you
can't hear Travis can you he's saying
it's not weird every time can you look
at Travis's expression it's not it's not
a positive he's not being helpful no
it's not weird stop stop just dismiss
everything is weird it's not weird stop
dismissing everything as weird he says
that and and I've heard Travis and the
other guys make fun of you in the office
for saying that every time something
goes wrong it's just really weird man
it's not it's just it's so weird Travis
is saying that you [ __ ] up and yeah I
don't know I don't know that system so
Dave you the the the Reuben report like
it that that's your that's your
livelihood in your baby right yeah if it
was just now if it just constantly we
just don't [ __ ] up and like and like
your producer was like yeah it's really
weird right wouldn't you be like I'm
gonna kill you today honestly any time
something goes wrong on my show it's my
fault like my guys are great my guys my
guys are all spies and David isn't that
weird if you really think about it yeah
and then and then Dave's guys are like
Dave why would you [ __ ] this up and dave
was like weird they refer to me as a
technical error they do is how they yeah
yeah my guys are never I mean this type
of thing this disaster that this is
becoming an obvious situation that's
going to continue off air as the show at
its height like it was like and that
whatever we were about to press was
gonna make enough with the staff stuff
you don't believe [ __ ] do you want me to
do the staff has left me with nothing
yeah it did derail things a bit cuz we
were gonna go to that clip I started
talking about it and I you know I try to
be fair about it but you're just you
know your incompetence it's just I don't
understand the system how to upload but
Travis saying you [ __ ] up and say I'm
saying you [ __ ] up yeah well I mean
look it's a load if I have like a thing
that says like here's some clips you can
go just right go like okay play the clip
and they're like that's not Neck lips
not there what did I get today's clip so
yesterday's Clips not there either
well they're in the successful file
[Laughter]
correct if successful folder is not good
what is the correct fold the ones you
don't want for the show that what you
can open right now
okay so Travis unfortunately after the
show today even though it's Friday you
will have to give Anthony another lesson
on how to on how to give you clips I'll
just yell do it again okay have you
showed him ready Travis of course I've
showed them a triathlete Travis
responsibility yeah of course I've
showed him
as before speaking with irritation and
exasperation why do you suppose that you
were doing it wrong I don't know I
screwed up my fault we know that but I
don't know he always goes I screwed up
here it's my fault and then he gives and
then he gives me the money line yeah I
think we're gonna get the money why okay
give it I think I think we're gonna get
a live one yeah I just want to like what
I want to do I never get a picture of
Troy you've never seen a happy
eager happy Troy I've never seen Troy
rest his chin on his with his elbow on
the counter and his chin on his fist and
he's just smiling and Anthony yeah as if
to say like I could leave you alone I
can completely leave you alone and let
it happen to you I've never seen just
such a content look a happy look on his
face right you had nothing to do with
this right you just let you let nature
take its letting it be up I really like
the way you guys operate this operation
really do because I can sense the way
you keep all your people kind of working
against each other blue collar what are
we gonna do to move forward I was gonna
say move forward successfully but I feel
like the word success has been over you
so what are we gonna do to move forward
in a fruitful way Anthony is also wrong
waiter okay Jim yeah um you know you
know in a way that will be beneficial to
the show how we're gonna move forward
from those points you from now on make
sure that all the drops are in there
before the show and is there is there
anything what I'd like to say to us may
be some type of apology maybe that I
[ __ ] up and I'm sorry and is this
something that is going to be repeated
no how would one say that sorry it won't
happen again comment Travis I'm sure
it'll happen Travis sighs says I'm
quoting okay
sure it'll happen together yeah Travis
does not have a whole lot of faith in
your ability to pull you should do it
like a betting pool that this is gonna
happen again well here's the problem
nobody would bet do you think it's gonna
happen about thirty more so you you
understand as a guy who's not here that
often but it will happen again oh yeah
for sure yeah yeah this is definitely my
son right here my son acts when he gets
caught how old is your son
oh he's 14 okay this is exactly so he
puts on the sad face in his head he's
just thinking about Madden I'm not
really thinking about apologize just how
do I play you punish him yeah the only
way I do it now is is the phone it's the
most effective way it is right really is
man I take the phone away yeah anything
else is nothing you say mommy you're all
that great look at I have my phone
you'll take the phone I'll take it yeah
I have his phone right now it's two I've
had it for two weeks
oh really strong yeah he's a he's a jerk
man this kids a [ __ ] [ __ ] yeah
[ __ ] [ __ ] I got this kuna you know
surveillance cameras around my house
it's attached to my phone yeah it like
anything moves sure it notifies me and
I'm on the road so it's a three-hour
difference so now it's by 30 in the
morning and my phone keeps going off in
my head I'm like raccoon whatever sure
always goes up but now it's like this
consistency so I'm like let me just
check randomly it's 2:30 in the morning
at my house and you see what's going on
bunch of dudes swimming and he's the
only one fully clothed because he's
getting ready for the cops to come you
know me because he knows I he knows he's
caught because he knows every time he
walked by the camera he's looking at it
Jim I have it on my phone I'll show it
to you why is he in there in their
trunks to go swim no top no nothing and
he's fully clothed hoodie on and he
keeps looking at the cameras as he's
walking to the plan so we're gonna be
like who's that guy in the hoodie yeah
yeah he thinks that it's not gonna wake
you up cuz it's so late no he told me he
knew he goes he goes every time he
walked to the pool I kept looking at the
cameras I go wat he goes cuz I knew
I just knew you were watching for soup
all at that moment yeah I called him at
that moment yeah and what did you say he
thought at first when I called I I go
what are you doing he went like this huh
what are you doing he was all I'm still
uh-huh oh yeah where are you he goes the
house I know you're at the house I'm
watching you [ __ ] on the phone right
now he's all we have anywhere to go
you guys stay at the UH you're a
princess when you sent him I don't know
it's weird right yeah weird it's like
it's 2:30 in the morning like I know one
place you could go to bed yeah literally
I was you I have that option on the
phone like you can call it call the cops
or you can talk so mad that I didn't do
that because that would have been funny
bigger to tell all four like stop right
there yeah are you [ __ ] you
don't mean
hey but I didn't I was just so I was so
[ __ ] just China and when you see him
doing stuff going I thought to him on
the on the inner did you know that dad's
why did you make him throw them out I do
that I dug oh they were all gone yeah
that uber home by I don't give a [ __ ]
what happens to him and you got the
phone and you should give me a phone
suing yeah he hasn't had it since and it
kills because it's like I can't check up
on him like I'm here in New York and I
want to call him after school and I
can't but now I got to be that dad and
and prove a point and sure how long you
keep this on for probably another year I
don't know he's a [ __ ] man he's pissy
he's got an empanada and uh and yeah he
has a tutor like I don't get it like
it's it sometimes math people were doing
so I asked him like I go is there
something else just tell me man I'm not
gonna get mad but he says he's just he's
blazing pot man that's
I don't know man I hope not but I'm
feeling that to action right now man no
he's at that age
where's the pot I put it in the folder
so weird it was just here your teacher
said that you didn't do your home
I know but I did it but I put it in a
successful successful folder I handed
the folder to the teacher and his
teacher said it's not there it's not
gonna happen again I'm sorry and I
[ __ ] up
I apologize someone happy